i kind of considered the way uh uh
blacksmithing and
most most trades have been um handed
down or across or whatever over you know
thousands of years and basically
you know it there has been the master or
journeyman apprentice system where
one person teaches a few other in his
life
and they you know they continue that
work and then you know as
things move along in the industrial era
uh factories wanted to make sure that
there were standards for production so
they might
keep mid-stage pieces around and have
drawings and
and specifications for their work
and the industrial economy might need
people who simply go to school and learn
this stuff but still it's gonna
generally amount to one teacher and a
dozen students or something like that
you know it's a
it's it's getting the word out uh
in maybe more effective way but uh i
have kind of realized that the best way
to
to do maybe a lot of this would be to
put
the knowledge online and i thought maybe
the best way to do it would be to forge
things in stages to make
the plastic flow of the material
obvious because it is quite obvious if
you can compare
two pieces that have only had 15 minutes
of work done between them you can see
what was done uh if you have only the
finished piece it's nearly impossible
to tell how it's done you can say in
theory oh yeah that's an asymmetric rap
but to do it is is a extreme amount of
work to
reproduce a piece and yet if somebody
does it
if they go to the work of making stages
then they can go and show people these
pieces
and it even a moderately experienced
smith
could suddenly i think make an axe you
know
maybe by a second or third try uh but it
also occurred to me
in doing that that i was carrying a box
of
40 pounds of unique
pieces which if i simply lost one would
be a
total pain in the ass i'd have to make
i'd have to make it over again
you know of course i have the left i
should be able to do it right because i
have the the previous pieces but
it would just be a terrific pain in the
ass and
uh and there's no reason for it to uh to
be that
dire so i just thought well what if we
just start scanning this stuff
the the uh the information conveyed by
any stage is simply its shape so the
easiest
thing to to get a 3d scan of would be
you know this chunk of iron it's flat
black
it's relatively small and you know it
represents a very specific stage
that would be nice to remember for a
long time
so basically a friend of mine at our one
of our california blacksmith oktoberfest
last year
had us had some sort of scanning
software and was using a digital camera
to make
3d scans of people and stuff
and i said well could you do a few of
these for me whitney potter so he
he did three pieces for me and sent me
the the 3d prints i thought this is
perfect it's like
hey it could be downloaded from online
it weighs like two ounces not two pounds
and it's not it's no longer unique it
could be printed out anywhere in the
world
and uh it could represent a process
extremely well maybe better than
anything that uh
you know you know not me you know maybe
one percent worse than having the actual
steel pieces but
you know still that the fact that it
could be uh downloaded a million times
you know is it's kind of awesome so and
uh did the facebook nerd friends in
scandinavia
are they uh the forging nerds i mean are
they
are were they using some of these
objects uh well
no no yes as a matter of fact they don't
i showed them this is like ooh
plastic you know it's like you don't get
it you don't get it it's gonna be the
next generation the academics are kind
of like
not so interested in smithing and the
smiths are not quite
you know making the connection or they
don't really necessarily know where to
get a scan
done but here you know in in you know
virtually in silicon valley this would
be the easiest thing to get done
and it seems like um you know if
somebody's willing to
collect the knowledge and make the
make the sequence that would be
relatively easy to
to put out there